euh vous préférez opposer la France
catholique et blanche à la France des
mouloudes et des rachides comprenez-vous
que Marine Le Pen porte plainte contre
Erric Dupont maéti on va voir cette
vidéo à l'Assemblée nationale et on en
parle juste après avec Olga giverernet
député renaissance de lin et Julien
odudoule député RN de Lyonne c'est parti
préférz en réalité opposer la France
rurale et tranquille catholique et
blanche à la France des cités la France
des Mohamed des mouloudes et des
vos propos sont incendiaires et ils
amènent dans la rue les militants de
l'ultra drroite pour être crédibl faites
le ménage chassez de vosang les gudards
les Identitaires les nazons les racistes
les antisémites les Français ne sont pas
dupes vous ne réussirez pas votre
entreprise malsaine vous faites croire
que les blancs sont menacés personne
n'est d ah je peux plus euh Olga
givverern merci d'être là député
renaissance de l'un et Julien audou
député Ren de l'autre euh non de Lyonne
oui ça va bien les deux merci d'être
c'est la première fois que vous venez
sur notre plateau oui merci de
l'invitation non c'est nous qui vous
remercions en tout cas de venir parce
que je pense ça va secouer un peu je
préfère vous le dire donc c'est bien et
bravo à vous parce que c'est vrai que
voilà ERC DUP pontourti c'est pas non
plus notre meilleur ami sur le plateau
hein je vous cache pas que voilà on a
d'autres amis mais pas lui euh voilà
donc en plus il est en forme il a été
relaxé là c'est fou ça ça va mieux bah
ça va mieux ouais donc c'est fini il est
tranquille là je crois qu'il est
tranquille après je sais pas s'il peut y
avoir des des rebondissements ou des
appels mais effectivement ça on
attendait la la la décision de savoir en
plus sil allait rester au gouvernement
là il y a pas de doute effectivement il
y a plus de doute il y a pas d'appel
possible pasapp quoi pas d'appel donc
non c'est c'est bon il a pas d'autres
affaires c'est la jus il est tranquille
il est relaxé là il est relaxe relax ah
oui là on sent qu'il est bien relax on
sent qu'il est bien relax euh alors il y
a un extrit je voulais vous montrer
avant qu'on avant qu'on parle de cette
affaire c'est l'édito de Laurence
Ferrari ce soir sur C news
euh bah regardez ce qu'a dit Laurence il
a acclamé son innocence depuis des mois
il a dénoncé son procès commetttant une
infamie il a estimé que les juges
menaient contre lui une vendetta
personnelle que les accusations de prise
illégale d'intérêt est une une invention
que c'était même lunaire je vous parle
du garde des saau lui-même Erric D
pomoretti qui a été relaxé cet
après-midi des accusations qui pesaient
contre lui personne ne sort gagnant de
ce procès à l'exception de Monsieur
Dupon Moretti qui a lavé son honneur
bafoué et qui a dénoncé avec fou
l'acharnement des juges contre lui mais
allit faire confiance à la justice après
cela le système entier semble avoir été
conçu pour les délinquants et pas pour
les honnêtes gens
voilà qui pense que qu'est-ce que vous
pensez dudito de Laurence Ferrari ben je
le trouve très pertinent je le trouve
dramatique aussi puisque il illustre et
symbolise une défiance des Français
vis-à-vis de l'institution Jud judiciire
et moi ce qui me navre avec le maintien
d'Éric Dupont Moretti c'est surtout le
maintien de sa politique le maintien de
son bilan qui est calamiteux qui est
désastreux et je pense qu'il y a des des
milliers voire des dizaines de milliers
de familles françaises qui ont souffert
d'injustice qui ont souffert de voir que
la loi quelquefois était plutôt du côté
du plus fort du côté des voyou du côté
des délinquants que la justice ne
protège pas assez qu'elle est pas assez
dure qu'elle est pas assez dissuasive
pour les délinquants et pour lutter
contre l'ensauvagement je pense que ce
soir il y a énormément de familles
françaises de victimes de familles de
victimes qui sont extrêmement déçu que
ce triste personnage parce que c'est un
triste personnage qui méprise
l'opposition qui insulte qui provoque
soit encore au ministère de la Justice
alors justement Marine Le Pen va porter
plainte contre le garde des sauts et
Éric Dupont moriti regardez nous allons
déposer devant la Cour de
justice une plainte pour que le ministre
se s'explique
de ces injures et accessoirement de ces
diffamations c'est malheureux d'en
arriver là mais encore une fois Monsieur
duupti joue une seule musique c'est la
musique de de l'injure de
l'outrance et nous n'entendons pas nous
soumettre à cela il ne nous intimide pas
et donc nous en appellerons à la cour de
justice qui doit finir par bien
connaître il a Jordan aussi qui a réagi
hein sur Europe 1 je sais pas qu'Al pro
écoutez monsieur Dupont Moretti se
comporte comme un chef de gang on est le
garde des saut et qu'on représente
l'institution judiciaire on est non
seulement impartial neutre mais on est
le ministre de tous les Français et je
pense qu'il nuit beaucoup à l'image de
la démocratie il nuit beaucoup à l'image
du débat public et surtout il nuit à
l'image de son gouvernement la dernière
fois que Monsieur Dupon Moretti s'est
présenté à une élection contre le
rassemblement national c'était au
régional de 2015 il avait fait 9 %.
alors moi j'ai cru comprendre que la
liste d'Emmanuel Macron aux élections
européennes en 6 mois avait du mal à
trouver une tête de liste donc je
propose à Monsieur Dupont Moretti de
prendre cette tête de liste du parti
présidentiel et de venir se confronter
sur le terrain électoral au
rassemblement national et j'espère pour
lui qu'il fera un peu plus de 9 % parce
que si tel était le cas ça serait la
honte absolu pour lui voilà alors est-ce
que ça vous fait réine oui pourquoi bah
je
suis contre tout ce que Marine Le Pen
tout ce que Monsieur Bardella et sans
doute tout ce que Monsieur monsieur Odou
le vont dire parce que je trouve que
Monsieur Dupont moréti que je porte pas
particulièrement dans mon cœur il a dit
des vérités et que dit quoi quand il dit
que le RN opposee la France blanche à la
France France catholique à la France des
mouloudes je trouve que c'est ce que
fait le RN en ce moment et que le RN a
joué sur les brises du drame des
arguments des exemples quelques
arguments quelques exemples excusez-moi
là on est parole contre parole Vous
portez plainte contre des paroles je dis
que ce que dit Monsieur dupom non non
mais est-ce que c'est vos paroles là oui
vous êtes d'accord avec les prop
oui vous jouez sur
les vous ne condamnez pas les marches
des groupuscules d'extrême droite vous
soufflez pas entendu Jordan Bardella
condamné molement vousz molement très
clairès vous ne voulez jamais entendre
voilà vous avez un problème à mon avis
il faut brancher le sonotone mais très
clairement VO en tout cas faut le
débrancher de
la tu peux pas dire molement c'est où on
a
c'est oui ou c'est non mais bon voilà
mais la France la France catholique
opposée à la France de de de moul je
suis d'accord c'est ce qu'il faut depuis
des semaine c'est ce que vous faites
depuis des semaines pour moi vous êtes
dangereux parce que vous soufflez sur
les BR on a après je voudrais
Jean-Michel mer laiss pas insulter nos
électeurs je suis désolé je suis désolé
mais une fois de plus tu m'exaspères
quoi parce que je précise pour tous les
éux qui voudraitent m'écrire après nai
jamais voté pour l' rassemblée nationale
d'ailleurs je ne vote pas aux élections
je sais que c'est pas bien mais c'est
comme ça voilà mais g ce qui qui met le
FA poudre c'est pas les propos de Marine
Le Pen qui mettent le fou de poudre
c'est les fait divivers qui semaine
après semaine exaspèent les Français et
les les actes deti qui laisse en liberté
des délinquants qui remet en délinquant
remet les délinquants en liberté au bout
de quelques semaines seulement de de
prison comme ça c'est ça qui exaspère
les Français c'est ce qui met le feu au
poudre c'est pas les propos de atttion
le gars quand même com faites attention
le gars quand excusez-moi excusez-moi
c'est ça qui exaspère les Français c'est
pas les propos de Marine Le Pen et si
elle grimpe autant dans les sondages
c'est parce que les Français sont
exaspérés c'est pas parce que elle elle
s'amuse à faire de la rhtorique tu étais
complètement à côté de la plaque
excuse-moi Olga giverern vous êtes
député Renaissance qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de de cette plainte contre Eric
du poriti alors moi je pense qu'il y a
pas du tout de fondement sur la plainte
hein la judiciarisation des rapports
sociaux on le voit à tous les niveaux je
trouve ça dommage que dans la politique
ce soit le cas il y a des des BAT des
passes d'armes il faut pouvoir en être
là moi Éric Dupont merti depuis qu'il
est au ministère il y a eu plus 11
milliards d'euros demi justement pour la
justice il y a
est il
plus a personnel plus pour PIR
traiter
qumeut éviter les opposer mais
efftivement la
justiceère j'aime bien j'aime bien
j'aime bien et puis en a un qui bosse et
puis l'autre
qui la question de la justice c'est
important qu'on a confiance dans notre
institution d'ailleurs c'est pas parce
que en
fait Mo faémission
quut tout de
suite é duupontti je vais vous dire
lanceer un sondage tiens l un sondage là
tout de suite en direct est-ce que vous
êtes content du travail d'Éric du pontti
est-ce que vous avez confiance en éc
duupont verity pour pour la justice
française on va voir et vous allez voir
si si on verra le sondage vous allez
voir il y a beaucoup de gens qui vont
voter et et et on a l'impression je vous
dis moi je fais l'émission tous les
soirs et j'ai énormément de témoignages
que on n jamais été dans dans un tel
marasme au niveau judiciaire c'est
catastrophique c'est ce que nous disent
tous les gens donc 11 milliards oui il
mais ils sont où moi les 11 milliards
qu'on donne 11 milliards je veux bien
moi aussi hein demain je peux donner 10
balles voilà mais non mais voilà non
mais non mais je vous dis non mais on va
tous donner mais je vous dis là pour le
moment j'ai on n jamais vu ça sachez-le
c'est à mon avis de la vie des gens je
vais demander au T spectateurs tiens
voilà qu-ce que je pens c'est le pire
ministre de la Justice qu'on a eu
excusez-moi le laxisme ambiance
excusez-moi donc voilà moi après moi il
par il y a quand même eu des circulaires
il y a quand même eu des circulaires qui
demandaient justement notamment au
moment des émeutes notamment au moment
où il y a où il y a ces rises d'avoir
une réponse ferme de la justice et c'est
vrai que la question d'avoir plus de
magistrats ça permet d'avoir une réponse
plus rapide et là je crois qu'on on
l'attend tout mais mais mais vous pensez
vraiment que les Français sont contents
du travail des règles du P on va voir on
va voir le le je moi je vais vous donner
le résultat du sondage he j'ai pas
besoin de je l'attends je l'attends vous
allez voir pas
non moi aussi je pense voilà sera pas 9
% je pense aussi non mais je vous dis
donc à un moment à un moment il faut
aussi euh le ministre de l'Intérieur euh
et la police il faut que la police soit
quand même aidée par le Garde des sauts
je suis désolé et aujourd'hui moi je
vous le dis et je vous le redis il y a
plein de potes policiers qui me disent
moi je te le dis je vais pas faire des
interventions les gars vont se retrouver
dehors demain ou après-demain qu'est-ce
que je vais me faire chier à prendre des
risques à mettre des
gars au trou alors qu'ils vont sortir
demain ou aprèsdain parce que ça ça
suivra pas derrière ouais mais il y a
quand même un état de droit enfin je
veux dire c'est dit arrête pas de me
dire à chaque fois qu'il va dans une
émission respter le droit par rapport
par rapport au à la législation qui est
en vigueur après si la législation do
doit changer et bien on est là nous
parlementaires pour pouvoir leire bouger
les choses mais il a fait bouger
quoi a fait bouger quoi bah la question
d'obtenir dans ses budgets pour pouir
avoir plus de Budet moi aussi peux
demain dire à ma mère
pass-mall il a laissé s'effondrer les
peines et quand on a un ministre de la
Justice qui déjà dès le premier jour de
sa nomination se fait acclamer par les
délinquants et les criminels à la prison
de freine quand vous avez un ministre de
la Justice qui dit que son boulot à lui
c'est de faire sortir les gens de prison
quand vous avez un ministre de la
Justice qui dit qu'il est le ministre
des détenus et des délinquants et pas
celui des victimes et des familles de
victimes ça pose problème et ça
interroge sur la philosophie de ce
gouvernement qui effectivement favorise
et encourage un laxisme et le laxisme
vous sa madame des gens très bien au
gouvernement il y a des gens moins bien
voilà le le laxisme malheureusement et
dans le climat d'ensuvagement que l'on
subit aujourd'hui dans le drame de crpol
et la triste illustration le laxisme
c'est un permis de tuer c'est un permis
de tuer pour les délinquants pour les
criminels pour les racailles qui se
sentent en totale impunité qui savent
pertinemment qu'il ne feront jamais un
jour de prison qui feront peut-être au
pire du travail d'intérêt général qui
aura un rappel à la loi mais que la
justice ne frappera pas aujourd'hui il
faut remettre les choses à l'endroit il
faut que la justice protèse les les
honnêtes gens il faut qu'ell soi sévère
et beaucoup plus sévère avec ceux qui
nous pourrissent le quotidien avec tous
ceux qui constituent une menace pour la
société pour le peuple français et
malheureusement RP Moretti c'est
véritablement le porte-parole de tous
ceux qui nous pourrissent le quotidien
parce qu'il ne veut pas sévir c'est ça
le problème vous voulez vous voulez vous
soutenez très certainement les actions
de l'ultradroite quand elle va dans les
quartiers pour pouvoir faire justice
soi-même je crois qu'avec le
trèsair on est d'accord mais avec le
discours que vous avez avec la
normalisation de l'extrême droite
excusez-moi mais là l'ultra droite est
complètement décomplexé vous parlez de
l'xisme je suis pas d'accord je ne suis
pas d'accord il y a des comparitions
immédiates il y a des peines qui sont
fait la peine la peine plchée ça ne
fonction
pasr a rien de fait il y a rien de fait
arrêtez arrêtez rien de fait oui alors
porter plainte moi je trouve que c'est
un peu ridicule dans un contexte où les
tribunaux sont plein et complètement
engorgés je trouve que c'est un peu
dérisoire ça c'est le premier aspect
après sur le la sortie de Dupont Moretti
le Dupont Moretti Comedy
Club ça bah c'est vrai c'est une énorme
par exemple contrairement à Jean-Michel
merire j'ai toujours voté et je n'ai
jamais voté pour le rassemblement
national mais malgré tout je trouve que
cette sortie là en fait on a un retour
en arrière dans les argumentations j'ai
l'impression qu'on s'attaque au
rassemblement national comme au Front
national dans les années 80 et 90 il
faut le faire faut le FA
m
4 ça fait 4 ans que la moié de la France
homesqu Tromp sur
cette une TTI perd n'a jamais permis au
rassemblement national de perdre des
voies bien au
contraire
3 qui ils étaient à ils sont à
33 faire le M dans
le c'était son intervention faites le
ménage dans vosang effectivement quand
on on le voit autour de ses amis et le
clan et le clan le P
demand en tout cas lui réussit à faire m
dans lesémicycl ils sont tous partis ils
ont qué ilst partis moi je suis désolé
je pense que te de d'
Duom la moitié de la France a voté pour
Madame Le Pen au second tour attendez
jeétais en train de vous parler la
moitié de la de la France a voté pour
Madame Le Pen au second tour et même si
en soi tout ce que dit Monsieur Dupon
Moretti peut tout à fait s'entendre la
chasse au nazillons au gudes et cetera
et de faire le ménage dans son propre
camp c'est une chose mais est-ce que on
est tous d'accord avec ça mais est-ce
que vous ne croyez pas que faire cet
amalgame là en réalité c'est une
tactique politicienne qui consiste à
dire le rassemblement national et égal
des gudard et je pense que au final pour
la population qui vote pour ce par c'est
bidon c'est bidon parce que ça n'a
jamais fait reculer ça ça fait 40 ans
que tous la moitié de enfin les hommes
politiques qui combattent le
rassemblement national utilisent cette
rangaine de l'amalgame et je pense que
ça ne fonctionne pas donc si vous
continuez comme ça c'est pas ça qui vous
permettra de vous maintenir au pouvoir
ou en tous les cas de de battre madame
le pen7 pour répondre effectivement vous
pouvez le penser on l'a pensé aussi à un
moment donné même le président de la
répuique ement finir que le Président de
la République a effectivement dit que
c'était pas le cas moi je reviens en
arrière sur mon département je Clive et
et et je ne souhaite pas être associé ni
dans l'organisation d'événements avec le
rassemblement national parce que parce
que c'est
le le le la dédiabolisation c'est
continuer de faire croire qu'en fait
c'est des députés comme les autres c'est
des parlementaires comme les autrut comm
les autr vous
êtes nous av éous les deux par les
Françis
ous même V d'ailleurs c'est même pas
républiain et là c'est là où vous murez
toujours toujours contre le
rassemblement national et contre toutes
les extrêmes de MO je précise jamais
voté pour le rassemblement national mais
je pense je suis fondamentalement
absolument certain que vous vous trompez
totalement il faut bien essayer il faut
bien continuer d'essayer quelque chose
je suis désolé Mo j'ai sur sur ma j'ai
regagné puisque j'étais aussi il y a
autre chose qui me choque et qui à mon
avis choque bien plus les Français
aujourd'hui c'est qu'à 15h monsieur
Dupont Moretti est relaxé dans ce qui
s'appelle un fiasco judiciaire parce que
quoi qu'il arrive ça restera un fiasco
judiciaire pour deux raisons la première
c'est que c'est quand même le Syndicat
de la magistrature lui-même donc ce sont
des gens qui sont quand même censés
savoir comment on fait une plainte et
bien ce sont eux qui ont porté plainte
contre leur ministre de tutelle monsieur
Dupont Moretti qui depuis toutes ces
années est censé représenter la justice
représenter tous les gens qui
aujourd'hui ont affaire avec la justice
on a des réquisitions deuxème raison qui
fait que c'est un fiasco judiciaire
c'est qu'on a un avocat général qui
n'est pas n'importe qui et qui dit une
année une peine d'un an avec surcis et
puis finalement alors et là pour le coup
personne ne comprend la la relaxe
finalement il est totalement relaxé par
qu'il y a une décision et un ça restera
un fiasco que vous le vouliez ou non je
respecte la décision de la
justice lae que c'est le Syndicat de la
magistrature mais c'est le syndicat de
la vous vous rendez compte c'est ce sont
des professionnels le Syndicat de la
magistrature c'est eux qui ont porte
donc je voudrais juste terminer avec ça
quel exemple parce que c'est un lien
avec le débat quel exemple on donne à la
France d'un ministre de la Justice qui
est accusé par son propre camp par les
propres magistrats
d'avoir été avoir fait un abus de
confiance d'une certaine façon d'avoir
abusé de son autorité c'est ce que je
cherchais comme terme finalement il est
relaxé sauf que il y a un avocat général
qui a dit ben vous avez peut-être tort
donc en fait on n pas complètement
rassuré et puis au final aujourd'hui 1
heure après ça c'était à 15h et à 16h il
commence à refaire de la politique tout
de suite et attaquer le rassemblement
national moi je défends absolument pas
le rassemblement national mais vouloir
opposer de France de façon aussi
caricaturale en disant il y a une France
blanche et de l'autre côté il y a une
France des rachides et
desoulme le mot
ch jusce mais ça me choque ça me choque
et et je vais non mais je te dis moi moi
je te dis ça aurait été un autre mec ça
aurait été un gars de chez eux ou un
gars de chez Mélenchon je le dis là je
le mets dedans là tu vois je vais le
défendre tu aurais dit la France des
moulous et des rachides frère ça aurait
été un tolé ce soir on aurait ça veut
dire quoi de dire la France des moulous
des des Rachid et lui il arrive il peut
tout se permettre hein non mais c'est
c'est une simplification de l'esprit et
en plus qu'il veut renvoyer à un autre
camp
politique exactement tu veux que je te
dise c'est de l'amalgame je vous dis et
ça et ça pour moi voy vous dis ça ça
divise la France dire la France des
Rach mataliseance pour moi c'est RAC
pour moi c'est r je vous dis ça pour moi
c'est raciste parce que ça veut dire
qu'il a quoi alors il y a plusieurs
Frances dans la tête de ERC dont y a
plusieurs Fran moi dans ma têteune
France c'est un raccourci